hey 42 here the Internet is big really
big is so big that if he tried to count
every web page you probably run out of
numbers or get really really bored the
Internet is also weird really weird for
every once in awhile someone finds
something on the Internet's that just
seems a bit too weird something's so
creepy and unexplainable it makes the
hairs on the back of your neck stand or
here's some of the most bizarre unsolved
mysteries of the internet a eight five
eight is the name of a mysterious
subreddit since 2011 the unknown owner
of the subreddit has been posting
thousands of long coded text messages to
the subreddit almost every day these
strange messages intrigued the reddit
community so much that a separate
subreddit with setup called solving a
eight five eight for the sole purpose of
attempting to decode the cryptic
messages the messages appears to be
written entirely in hexadecimal which is
the numerical notation system used in
computer programs thousands of people
have employed a range of advanced code
breaking techniques in an attempt to
crack the codes but the messages and the
person behind them still remain a
mystery
secada free--free 0-1 is arguably the
most mysterious of all internet
mysteries it all started on January the
5th 2012 when an anonymous 4chan user
posted this peculiar black-and-white
image on the random board
it reads hello we are looking for highly
intelligent individuals to find them we
have devised a test there is a message
hidden in this image find it and it will
lead you on the road to finding ghosts
we look forward to meeting the few that
will make it all the way through good
luck free frizzy rat one naturally this
sent the internet crazy trying to find
the hidden message within the image
until Joe
Eriksson a 34 year old computer analyst
from Sweden found the message he knew it
was an example of digital steganography
a way of hiding encoded messages within
the pixels of an image Ericsson decoded
the hidden message and what he found was
a reference to Tiberius Claudius Caesar
under string of meaningless letters
Eriksson worked out it was a cipher
system used by Julius Caesar in private
correspondence from Nats he found a new
web address which contained another clue
and so the trail continued for a long
time each clue got increasingly complex
and more difficult to solve nobody is
sure if anyone has actually solved all
the puzzles and got to the end of the
rabbit hole however a month after the
first puzzle was posted a new message
was posted to the four cheong message
board that reads we have now found the
individuals we sought thus our
month-long journey ends nobody knows who
is behind this internet treasure hunt
and what happens to the winners some
theorize that Secada free--free 0/1 is a
recruitment method for a global spy
organization such as mi6 or the CIA
that's are seeking code breakers with
brilliant minds over say this a card a
free free zero one group is comprised of
military officers diplomats and
world-class academics whom are unhappy
with the current state of the world and
are seeking out only the most
intelligent minds from across the globe
to become part of some new world order
yet to this day Saqqara free free zero
one remains one of the greatest unsolved
mysteries of the internet what's even
creepier about Secada free free zero one
is that this isn't just some random guy
in his parents basement playing a
gargantuan practical joke on the
internet because the puzzles led the
participants offline as well
requiring people to find posters at
specific coordinates all over the globe
including Russia Japan France South
Korea
and the USA which must mean that the
Secada free phi0 one group is a large
well-funded global organization each
year since Secada free free zero watt
has posted a new puzzle on the 5th of
January and a new game begins but nobody
ever hears from the winners after they
reached the end of the endless maze of
mind-bending puzzles we can only assume
that whatever they are up to they have
been sworn to absolute secrecy at number
3 is the Deep Web the websites you visit
every day such as Facebook and Google
are only a very small tip of the
gigantic iceberg that is the Internet
however 80% of the entire Internet is
not indexed by any search engine and can
only be accessed by using special
applications such as tor this section of
the internet is called a Deep Web and
it's mostly stuff you don't want to see
such as online illicit drug marketplaces
stolen credit card numbers human
trafficking weapons and even hitmen for
hire as well as a bunch of other shady
stuff nobody knows exactly what's
contained within the Deep Web because
the majority of it isn't listed in any
index or search engine however it said
that you can buy literally anything on
the Deep Web and absolutely any illegal
on the various thing you can imagine you
can guarantee will be happening
somewhere within the Deep Web if you
think the Deep Web sounds mysterious you
can go even deeper there's a hidden
level of the internets below the Deep
Web so deep that nobody has ever been
able to access it at least not that we
know of
it's called Marianas web named after the
deepest ocean trench on earth Marianas
web is rumored to contain a repository
of all of humanity's best-kept secrets
including the location of Atlantis it is
basically the internet version of the
Vatican secret archives
some even say that Marianas web is the
home of a super intelligent computer
artificial intelligence that has become
sentient and overlooks and also controls
the entire Internet like some omnipotent
internet mother nature it is said that's
in order to access Marianas web one must
use Pali metric palcohol derivation
which is a high-level mass function that
requires quantum computers to work and
quantum computers do not yet exist
however this level of the web is only
rumored to exist and is most likely just
an Internet hoax webdriver torso is the
name of an uncanny YouTube channel
starting in September 2013 almost every
single minute since 24 hours a day a new
11 second video has been uploaded to the
channel however unlike most YouTube
videos in webdriver torso videos there's
not a single cut to be seen every single
video is a series of random blue and red
shapes accompanied by beeping sounds
some big company such as the BBC have
taken an interest in this conundrum and
put code breakers to work to attempt to
figure out what the webdriver torso
YouTube channel is all about what some
people think it's a modern version of a
number station which were cryptic radio
signals used during the Cold War to send
messages to spies what other people
think these 11 second video clips are
communications from aliens but I'm
afraid to say that this YouTube channel
is highly unlikely to be anything
malicious in June 2014 it was discovered
to be nothing more than a test account
maintained by Google themselves after
Engadget emailed Google about the
channel and they replied with this witty
response we're never gonna give you up
loading that slow or losses video
quality and we're never gonna let you
down
by playing YouTube in poor video quality
that's why we're always running tests
like webdriver torso
however some skeptics still believe that
this is just a cover-up by Google and
that webdriver torso may still have some
alternative motive thanks for the view
subscribe for more thoughty2